put away your phone this is the single
most important part of your day because
we've just learned the secret to what
makes Donald Trump the most powerful
president ever take it in in former
campaign manager Corey lewandowski's new
book let Trump beat Trump he lets us in
on a typical Trump dinner
a big man 540 calories times two fillet
of fish 410 calories times 2 a small
chocolate shake 530 calories Oh typical
liberals first you ought to ascribe a
point value to food then you get mad
when Donald Trump gets the high score
shame game Trump knows what he wants and
in this case it's 2,400 calories in one
meal it's so efficient he eats more than
a day's worth of calories in one sitting
don't take it from me take it from his
former campaign manager the purpose of
the this passage of the book and let
Trump be Trump was to show that he's
ready to do the next thing he just want
to sit down for a meal he ate quick
there was always something else to do
he's an absolute machine he works his
staff harder than humanly possible
because he out works them all hey he's
more than a human
he's a well-oiled machine gear slathered
in tartar sauce now of course those
dollar menu haters on the left or
critical of Trump's meal calling it
absurd disturbing at best and bombastic
folly well I hate critics they're
cowards so I'm going to prove them wrong
bring on the mega meal
thank you to hell with your vegetable
garden Michelle Obama this is a meal
that fuels greatness this is the mega
meal challenge I promise to eat this
entire Trump spread right here right now
and I'll do it while covering Trump's
most recent bold decision declaring
Jerusalem the capital of Israel defying
vocal opponents president Trump today
recognized Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel didn't candidate Trump made a
campaign promise to recognize Jerusalem
as the Israeli capital now as president
he has gone down a road in reality they
failed to deliver today I am
[Applause]
I suppose Ashley was very oh oh it goes
out easy when you take a big aggressive
swing one thing you go wrong
I've loaded that right now Donald I feel
great this this is just the right amount
of meat my insides feel thick my blood
sugar is spiking and I'm in the mood to
make good fast decisions affect norm I'm
gonna make one right now Timbo
get on out here help me tell this story
man come on everybody here you will not
regret this George all right Jim break
it down you're an expert on the Middle
East well technically the Middle West
Joel go go
specifically the Midwest go Fighting
Illini now focus on your brain food
Jordan no you look great by the way
you have I was gonna say you have a
healthy glow about you and I'm loving it
well okay okay okay now with this
Jerusalem move
president Trump has knocked it out of
the park once again and just like every
great Trump decision the liberal elites
absolutely hate it why is he doing this
now why poke the hornet's nest it's
questionable because there's already so
much going on around the world leaders
across the globe even the Pope voicing
opposition Jordan's King Abdullah
predicted the decision will provoke
Muslims and Christians alike Turkey's
Deputy Prime Minister called it an act
of madness that will plunge the region
of the world into a fire with no end in
sight and Palestinian Authority
President Mahmoud Abbas warned President
Trump that this could have dangerous
consequences for peace efforts it sets
back the peace process by decades and it
alienates our other allies oil is just
pushing down and almost back up at the
boom
Milly's piddly oh yeah that's good
though it's omega threes
now Jordan there's nothing wrong with
being set back I did third grade thrice
times and now I host this TV show logo
all right keep you two go boy everyone
is saying Trump acted without thinking I
say never waste any time thinking that's
how you get cold feet
you don't want cold feet you have cold
feet Jordan they're surprisingly hot
right now well stay focused I want to
show you that the proof that Donald
Trump is making things happen just look
at what's happening in the streets today
Palestinians gathered to protest against
President Trump's decision to recognize
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel
we've been watching young groups of men
crying steins anything else they can
find as security forces they didn't
shoot back with Palestinian protesters
set fires in Gaza this morning and
chanted death to America oh I don't
understand why they hate us
[Applause]
nevertheless sometimes plunging the
world into fire is the best way to solve
a problem it's like how I let my hyundai
sonata on fire so I didn't have to make
car payments anymore look no one solved
this whole Middle East peace thing Trump
is the only president with the nuggets
to do something totally unexpected
baby maybe even unilaterally wrong just
to shake things up make people sick with
your decisions cause them wretch from
how strong your resolve is Jam the
decision down just like my boy Jordan
now he promised to complete the nagas
meal champ oh look at him he looks
amazing like a brave leader a hulking
beat crusher a Ken doll with huge balls
look at that face America that is the
face of our country's future
[Applause]
you got your leader juice yeah yeah you
know little hazy blurry pain and colors
I want to make some decisions just me
okay
Jerusalem capital move it the wall build
it North Korea Luke oh yeah you can ask
Jordan go now we'll never be able to get
inside a president Trump's mine but we
can get inside his voluptuous gut and
that's where the decisions come from god
I want to take a nap
yeah yeah that's right oh that's right
Jordan and do it in that order don't mix
up I mix them up a hundred times oh now
just imagine how clear you'd be thinking
if you ate this meal every day
[Music]